this lab in new york and others around
the world are racing to answer one of
the most important questions we have
right now
how well will our current vaccines
protect us from omicron that new
worrisome coveted variant as we expected
damacrine is quite resistant so it
evades
detection and inhibition by the
antibodies we produce either after
vaccination or prior infection however
there's also good news a booster it
maintains a level of activity against
omicron that should be sufficient to
provide protection the lab at
rockefeller university is one of the
leaders doing these types of experiments
so i went to get an exclusive look at
the kinds of tests ferologists need to
do to come up with those conclusions and
what the results might mean for us going
forward
when i visited virologists theodora
hatsuyano and paul benosh were about to
finish some key experiments since around
thanksgiving their lab has been working
around the clock on omicron
they've been testing antibodies in
samples from three groups people who
have recovered from covet some of whom
got vaccinated people who have gotten
boosters of pfizer's vaccine and people
who just got a single dose of the j j
shot
the testing involves looking at a key
part of the virus plus patient samples
like this one and then how the
antibodies in those samples interact
with the virus we're basically mimicking
what happens uh in your body when the
virus enters your body and encounters
your antibodies during my visit theodore
showed me a kind of heat map of antibody
virus interactions if it's capable of
inhibiting virus infection you will turn
the red into
light
orange green and even blue if the plasma
is quite powerful
like an alert the more red you see the
less effective antibodies are at
attacking the virus and the more of it
that can get into cells
that's what happened when they tested
omicron the day after my visit they had
the results
some neutralization neutralization or
the ability of antibodies to keep
omicron from entering cells was
generally lower in paul and theodora's
experiments the data corroborates what
corporate and academic labs have found
so far that current vaccines may be less
effective against omicron than previous
versions of the virus theodoras and
other researchers data point to a future
where boosters are the norm and vaccines
get tailored to specific variants
it really means you should get a booster
as soon as possible
and it should ex boosters should be
extended all age categories including
kids so how do the tests that help guide
our vaccine strategy actually work
researchers start by building a
lab-grown version of omicron's spike
protein from scratch the spike protein
is what helps the virus get into cells
it's also a key target for virus busting
antibodies
fabian schmidt is the researcher in
charge of reconstructing the spike
protein he gave me a tour of the
building process starting with an online
database of viral genetic sequences so
you see south african
and then
this is now even allocated omicron
that genetic information serves as the
blueprint for omicron spike the
researchers use bacterial cells to copy
that genetic code
each one of the dots you see here
represents a clone or a specimen of
spike protein dna
the other piece of the puzzle is the
shell of a completely different virus to
which they attach the lab-grown omicron
spike protein these are basically
neutered viruses
they can get into cells but they lack
the machinery to reproduce and spread
that's key because it's what allows the
researchers to measure the extent to
which antibodies can stop the spike
protein from getting these fake viruses
to latch onto and infect cells
in a separate and secured section of the
lab the researchers incubate their fake
virus with patient samples from
vaccinated people and people who've had
coveted that liquid has antibodies
the virus antibody mixture is then added
to cells that have been sitting in a
warm incubator inside these little black
containers
critically these cells have the receptor
that the spike protein binds to allowing
the virus to enter if the neutered virus
gets in it varies a set of instructions
that tells the cells to make luciferase
that's a protein that glows and is
measured by the instrument theodora
showed us earlier
more glow means more infection which is
shown in red that means the antibodies
were less effective
they compared how well antibodies
prevented omicron spike from helping the
virus get into cells relative to the
original version of spike and they found
that the antibodies in our body
particularly over time appear really
poor at uh dealing with omicron the
samples they tested from patients
spanned several months from right after
they were vaccinated or infected to
months later and we know that antibody
levels tend to wane with time plus none
of these people were infected with
omicron when people got boosters though
their antibody levels went up and still
retained sufficient activity to make us
hopeful that these people will be able
to deal with omicron infections
the adora said that the extra antibodies
that boosters provide should help
protect us against the most severe
outcomes including hospitalization i
still remain worried that irmicron will
transmit between vaccinated people
easier so we still need to have masks
and social distancing for a little while
longer in the coming weeks we should
have more definitive answers about
omicron's real world impact from data on
how well vaccines protect people not
just cells
public health experts will be able to
see whether vaccinated people are
getting more breakthrough infections
those have tended to be milder but what
is really driving evolution and
emergence of the variants is resistant
to antibody responses
theodora another said that vaccination
rates need to increase to give the virus
fewer chances to infect mutate and pose
new threats in the future
[Music]